you've said that calories matter I saw
Dr Giles yield and he said calories tell
you absolutely nothing child professor
of genetics at Cambridge I think he's
he's an incredible guy what Giles yo
will say is calories matter yes but
there are limitations within that for
example it is very difficult to
accurately quantify how many calories
you're consuming it doesn't matter how
meticulous someone is with calorie
counting calorie counting is nearly
impossible to get perfectly accurately
and often that's for reasons outside of
your control the nutritional information
is allowed a natural variance so just
because something says it's 100 calories
doesn't mean it's 100 it might be 110 it
might be 90. also the way you prepare
food for example can change the calorie
content of that food or the energy
content of that food if you juice
vegetables you can remove fiber if it
removes the fiber you have changed the
qualities of that food